each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
good morning it's my pleasure to
introduce professor Java Han from the
University of Illinois urbana-champaign
and I want to thank dong who is really
the host who has acted but he very
kindly we can ask me to sort of
introduce professor Han so I'm doing
that so professor yamaha almost said all
of you probably know he's been really
prolific in the area you know data
mining data warehousing with here strike
over 400 publications in major you know
major conferences and journals he was
awarded the highest honor of the sem CKD
d which is the special interest group or
knowledge and data mining he got the k
DD innovations award which is the
highest recognition in this sub field in
addition he is a founding editor of the
ACM transactions and knowledge discovery
again that he really made happen and it
has really flourished since then he has
a book data mining concepts and
techniques that has been used as a
textbook worldwide he has been in
numerous program committees has been the
PC chair for k DD STM the and also the
ice EDM conference all major data mining
conferences and as you can see his work
is over regarded that all you know in
the sponsors list you can almost you
know see everyone that could have
possibly sponsor that shut off speaks to
his being a very prolific contributor in
a technical so welcome and thank you
okay yes thanks sex is to search it for
the nice introduction it is my pleasure
to with microsoft research I think
that's for quite a few years I mean not
really come to Microsoft Research being
busy work out many things so today I'm
going to discuss more mining knowledge
from database especially here we have a
very strong database group I was
thinking about no linking data mining
waste databases using a new master card
information effort
analysis approach the work actually has
been done together with several of my
PhD students actually xiao xin is now
Microsoft Research member right sitting
here so and the two other students are
in a newer one sincerely under the ph.d
program okay so for about database and
the information networks people
originally is thinking these are two
very different things databases people
doing transaction management kun doing
query processing storage and all these
things and information networks people
are more thinking about like social
networks Twitter's or you know Facebook
actually if you really think about these
two things there are some inherent links
which is very interesting so the first
thing is about this traditional view of
database most people are thinking
database is a data repository and David
system usually doing like transaction
management data retrieval quarrying
updates you know indexing all these
different games but on your hand if we
have another view for example from a
data miners Field you say database
accurate organized information networks
okay why because not only data
themselves they have structure records
but they also linked to different things
we know for example you have joins you
link to the other things even you do not
really do joins they inherently the link
together okay so to the extent we are
thinking the database actually
information-rich interrelated data
relation and they form really really
huge okay information network another
interesting seeing different from other
information network is it is
interconnected it is multiple typed to
some extent you can say this is where
structured information network comparing
to summer net other networks they are
not so structured okay
then i'm going to show you if i say this
one is DB internet its database internet
we actually can derive surprisingly rich
knowledge from the database information
networks and you are going to see it so
that means if we want to uncover or
discover knowledge from the database we
better view this one as a network then
we do link exploration link analysis
then you probably see there's something
amazing we can get up okay so instead of
it is showing you something very
abstract I just show you very concrete
debates probably everybody understand
its DB RP ok unfortunately this DVR p is
only one huge davis instead of it you
get a complicated entity-relationship
data modeling many many different
relations together that one current hair
do not have a very concrete example to
show you but I just show you this one DB
RP data if we know this why is not too
small you get a millions of records
you're going to almost half a mini
Arthur's and you get a thousands or tens
of thousands of conferences okay with
this we linked together where things may
happen okay you're proven say can I
derive some interesting knowledge from
the state ways actually for example you
may say what are the popular or growing
research fields or safir's in computer
science or you want to say who are the
leading researchers on database or just
on X queries or something or you say
whether the different stuff years
whether the author collaborate evolve
and all these things or you even want to
know for example we found there shouting
did how many way walls just the same
name okay and which paper belongs to
which way was or something or you just
say even search brand did not get a PhD
who are his who was his supervisor okay
so or you want to know who are very
similar to Chris those valises those are
the very simple a very typical question
the problem is whether you just take the
VRP
whether we can mine it how we can answer
those strange for AIDS or something so
this actually work i'm going to show you
all these questions actually can be
answered readily and also can be
answered efficiently in this network
okay so you will see something pretty
interesting so the first thing i
probably will just give you a link what
is information network you probably
heard a lot of social networks like
Twitter's or you know Facebook all these
things but on your hand if we look at
the information network we can say this
is someone more general than social
network why because social network just
link people with people okay but
information effort to link objects with
other objects okay but objects could be
people as well so that's why the social
network is just part of the big
information networks okay for example
you think about DVR p not only you
linked with your co-authors but actually
you link with the conferences with
different keywords you know like
different sub fears so it is richer than
just the people linking with people okay
then actually people already study lots
of networks but we try to categorize the
network into two different categories
one week or homogeneous network another
week or heterogeneous network how much
in your network means when you link
things you link the same type okay just
thinking about you got facebook you say
i linked with my friends and friends
link who is friends those are
homogeneous one even you think about a
page rank okay people say webpage link
to the other web page indoors the other
web pages these are page link ways pages
this is syre homogeneous okay but what a
heterogeneous one you were thinking
about multiple types this is exactly
like a database using oh this entity
linghu the other entities okay that
forms heterogeneous multi type the
network just give you some for example
like a medical network you have patients
doctors disease contacts treatments are
these things remember both doctors and
patients are human okay but on your hand
they play very different roles patient
link who is patient and patiently
linquist
duckling go dr. a very different ok so
the same scene as a bibliographic
network like a DVR pee you get-a
publications authors venues terms or
these are linked together ok so those
are heterogeneous information networks
ok if you look at a web scare everybody
knows this is very important get a web
is big network or protein get a protein
networks by all networks co-author get
networks here i do not even sure
networks you see social network sites
because there are so many ok but you
know you got it like a facebook or
something they claim they have 100
million you know even this number now I
was touring 300 minute ok but anyway it
is a very big thing but if we categorize
networking two kinds for example
co-author network in BB RP you will say
this is more like homogeneous one but
you get a conference author link has
network this one is heterogeneous way
even just two types okay now if we want
to mind this network okay the first
interesting thing is we were thinking
about a clustering ranking of
heterogeneous information network so you
may say why we want a clustering and
ranking actually this clustering ranking
regularly practice in any network you
just think about this okay the first
thing is before even like a Google came
okay most people you meet other people
say gimme you I are okay why give me you
are air because otherwise you may not
even be able to find this researcher
okay you have to go through you know
like a Stanford University go to
computer science department no you would
know those gopher or something you know
you go down you know it's a painful okay
that's the reason people start your
links i use my webpage link to a lot of
database researchers because i don't
want to keep crawling but with google
why Google is interesting its ranking
okay if you say you'll get a name say
you know Jeff Armand okay then you if
you say oh 10,000 pages found you have
no time you know if they are not ranked
you probably abandoned this but if they
are ranked you find a home
homepage right on the top then that's
nice so that's why ranking become
critical for any network the clustering
is also very important because that you
you cannot find clusters you you get the
network like a millions of knows how
could you search how could you
comprehend but the problem most people
are thinking is ranking and clustering
or two things okay but actually ranking
clustering really should work together
thinking about this I say rank all the
people in academia okay you would say oh
it's a computer science or physics okay
even get comparisons you see is database
or Dave mining or III okay so you know
you have to make sense instead of
comparing chicken with ducks you just
comparing within the pier some sales so
that's why you need clustering and also
you need ranking I actually will show
you for example you mix database and
architecture together you try to rank
them you'll get garbage okay just these
two okay so that's the reason we say we
need to do both but people usually think
they can first look clustering into
ranking or first two ranking they do
clustering actually we we're going to
show you if you took clattering ranking
these two process together integrate
them together you get much better
clustering and much better ranking and
much more efficient processing as well
okay so you will see that's something
pretty interesting the paper actually
published last year ed BTE Joe sent her
paper actually we were thinking is very
novel in the sense you're really getting
two things together you get better on
both sides and a more efficient on both
sides ok so I firstly just minger this
database data mining which day hardware
a computer architecture these two
communities together merge them in DB RP
see what I will get you this left side
is what I got what I got here actually
is I look at it as to my surprise okay I
even the first top-five and cannot find
Sigma of your DB okay you as you can see
the Sigma V R DVR in the total twenty
conferences
no the top-ranked oh why I'm here d be
Sigma I CD was number eight to ten or
something that's pretty dismal and if
you love the researchers even even more
you know disappointing because I barely
recognize any way except I had no chase
and Kong not because he's a database
person just because he was a serious
error a department head and also
graduate from UIC that's why I know him
I'll hide i won't melt actually if you
really partition them okay you do
cluster the you two ranking you can see
this is the ranking in one of our
parameters or system you get a beer DB
sigma like this okay our Terry yvr DB on
top then Sigma okay but anyway these are
the researchers are we in one of our
running you know getting this okay yes
oh this for a ranking later I'll show
you this is just to say we do clustering
for each cluster we get top ranked list
sector you can rank learn pretty long
user basically you can enter something
like a clustering computer science or
classroom and ranking comparisons
someone like that okay so if you think
about it this whole process we just take
this rank class the DB ARP network okay
but we take a shorter or simplified
version it's only two things this part
is conference ok show you is database
data money and AI conferences okay and
here is just a bunch of researchers the
link in different ways okay what you can
see is for this kind of a study you
don't even want to do natural language
processing okay these are just links
this is like a Google game you just get
links you link them together then you
analyze it what do you do you can do
ranking using some kind of ranking rules
i'm going to show you what are the
ranking rules but you use ranking you
get different things okay then based on
this you in them in the middle of the
loop okay the first ranking may not be
even good okay you go to clustering then
you go back to ranking clustering turn
this one beam after a few rounds you're
fine it's amazing good clustering and
ranking on boats okay so you may say why
I have to do that you you say if I were
you I will first do clustering okay
because I know Davis is a cluster you
know a is and a cluster I why bother to
do ranking okay there's why intuition
you probably will be commenced okay
suppose you got one you know I got one
huge student trying to do Davis okay
maybe some it to some kind of workshop
get a paper on TV RP and here we have
swayed chattery got it hands up papers
and the very influential okay when I
rank this to wouldn't I get this class
ring does this to people were wait
exactly same when I clustering database
cluster different is not
okay why I guess so its charter with so
many years so many publications
influential with the first year PhD
student got one paper there in a
workshop they are different so if we
want to do meaningful get good
clustering you have a think not everyone
is equal okay so if we think about this
what about it give a little more weight
as a highly-ranked guys so you get
better cluster or get worst class likely
even semantically you'll get a better
cluster so that's what I'm motivation we
want to do that ok so this rank last
philosophy starting not treating every
note ii corps ok that's a changing of
the game but it's a nice change of the
game okay so now you can see why we want
to rank in classroom together the first
thing is we say they can be mutually
enhance mutually improved okay ranking
if you can do cluster the ranking become
more accurate but if you can do you know
both things you know very interesting
thing is we said not everybody body not
every Bob objected be treated equally in
clustering actually that's the different
game of clustering but why the other
people don't think about this way they
treat every object just the same as the
hard clustering game is doing this but
it should not okay so with a network you
actually will treat something you think
they are different they are very close
for example you think of weird EVN Sigma
they are different if you do natural
language processing you will see there
you know edit distance X is 3 far away
but on the other hand we know they are
so close so that's the reason you think
they are different maybe they are same
you think they are same they are
different ok so the game should be
changed now we look at this algorithm
the algorithm we work out if you think
about this it's pretty simple
initialization we don't have knowledge
we can randomly parties you anything
okay but with random punishing anything
into K clusters suppose you say i want
holcomb percents partying in 220
clusters you can do that randomly okay
then what you do for ranking is you can
kick in some kind of ranking rules i'm
going to show you what I ranking rules
immediately yes yeah these are when you
cluster them the notes you first don't
even consider the graphs just to say
knows are separated okay of course once
he separated the network could be
separately but you don't care that much
about it whether it's mean cuts or max
cards you don't care okay because this
is very rough just a graph you just take
notes you just put them in randomly into
different clusters that's it ok it's
very to me yes the object function later
you'll get this so the ranking actually
will do you know like you take some
ranking rules later i'm going to show
you everybody if you want different
thing you can get different ranking
rules ok then you can generate new
measure space based on this you say oh
this one agree in this cluster could be
maximized or somehow you get it get some
function then you can adjust your
cluster ok once you're just a cluster
you'll repeat step 1 ranked again you
generally measure space again adjust
again ok turn this into loop if you know
k-means you know II am this is a similar
game except you put the ranking in the
middle ok now in the real network of
course all the network most people on
the play is a matrix ok you just
thinking you get matrix of conferences
and authors and conference and authors
ok so if you take a conference as X
authors why this is author publishing
the conference compliment conference
takes the authors and this is also
linked with authors by initiate just
co-authors and here conferencing
conference initially is empty ok even
Sigma and VOD be and not linked ok so
then after few rounds you will see who
and who will be linked together closer
so now we get into this ranking ok and
we test the two ranking strategies one
week are simple ranking another
her Authority drink okay what is simple
ranking simple ranking is very easy you
just take those links okay you get more
links to get more ranks okay just
thinking you publish more papers okay
you rank higher okay or you the
conference took more papers the
conference could run high but that may
not be quite right thinking about this
if some guy got a paper or rejected they
say all set our own workshop we publish
20 papers in this wet works you have a
conference that's it okay maybe it will
be indexed by DB RV but remember there's
a one golden rule okay the golden rule
we can do for this Authority checking is
you have to restrict you see whether the
author could be ranked it's not only you
publish papers you publishing highly
ranked conferences like Sigma V relieve
me those conferences you probably in a
junkie some your serapha workshop it
doesn't hot okay but how could you know
which conference is highly ranked we
don't want anybody to train it okay what
we do is with a highly ranked
conferences attracted many papers from
many highly rec we their double Manning
okay not only taking more papers you'll
be here you have to take more papers for
many highly ranked Arthur's if you
instead of bogus conference I bet it you
know people here we're not even joy okay
so that's a reason the highly ranked
authors actually the highly ranked
authors many were dictated this highly
ranked conferences okay and also we
actually see the rank of author is
enhanced if you cooler with some highly
ranked hawsers okay that one were
distinguished for example you get into
like a stanford university with a
university or Community College the
reason is you can publish paper but you
probably should stand for you co-author
with some big-name guys pretty get more
credits than you publish one paper in it
by a community college with no neighbors
okay so if we know this is a rule we can
encode this rule in our matrix form okay
actually this rule warming code in this
way rule 2
and rules three okay rule 3 because the
people disagree each other on
collaboration how much weight he can get
so we put alpha as a parameter you can
sliding the bar and say I like the
collaboration or hate collaboration
whatever you can slide it you get
different weights okay so then we play
the game just to go back to this 20
conference minger with database and the
hardware now you see with this rank
class we put in the middle you will see
one line the green line is the hardware
one and the red line is database and a
mining one you press see the space after
surfing intuitions they are we're
separated on the ranking you can see the
highly ranked guys here will be very low
ranked here the same thing highly ranked
here will be better very low rank here
okay so they are very savory community
of course I take this to community now
take databases data mining as well
because it's a little harder okay to to
top our teaching them then we get into
our step two is generating new measure
space using mixed model okay this is a
little statistic game basically is you
just use it using those you know
conditional probability you get this
model you think they are generating
model then your finery can get some kind
of maximizing the log-likelihood but I'm
not going to get into very detail you
know just a very typical traditional
statistic game you can get it okay then
you actually can see after two or three
iterations this too you know cluster not
only ranking a separated the cluster
we're separated this is database called
a mining cluster this hardware computer
architecture class they are far apart so
now you'll get into after this you to
cluster adjusting ok adjusting basically
remember we do this clustering is
centuries like EML go this is not a
k-means so you got is a soft clustering
succour soft is you can say oh you
belong today base 0.83 percent or
something like that but it would be
on to the others or maybe 0.05 or 0.05
is you know different thing it's not
like one percent a 100-percent be okay
then you see this this is initially
initially you'll probably see because
it's random okay so somehow the two
things actually mixed up even when we do
initial we're actually getting like you
add up a little so the ranking if you
got a natural again more papers you get
it or higher ranking so it's not a
completed random here but you look at a
cluster they really mean go together
okay but then you after you do ye
Thracian two iterations reiteration they
become stable you see they have we're
separate okay so it's very small number
iteration you actually can get it done
complexity okay people say network user
is very complicated you have to do use
cloud computing you know like you know
very powerful things you do to do this
in many cases like in Google definitely
needed but here we play a different game
why even we get this DB RP network the
game is different from sim rank you
pretty her sim Rehnquist I'm by Jennifer
Williams group in stanford university
they they rank and cluster networks
mostly you know what they do is they
calculate every two nose in Derek
calculator similarity sink every two
notes okay how many nodes you have you
have n nodes every tool you get N
squared pairs and they are not only
compute directly computers their
computing your first neighbor then your
neighbors neighbor your neighbors
neighbor ok that's the complexity you
have the bear you get a quadratic number
of this pairs and you should pair your
computer links and links and links okay
you can hurry optimize it better because
thinking of quadratic plus those links
the complexity is there for us why we
got a linear algorithm okay the reason
is every time we evaluated number you
your distance to the center of the
cluster how many centers if you say I
want to get
many clusters you have 20 centers 20 is
a constant you get million people many
papers you get only 20 centers okay so
that's why this K you said k10 take a is
20 k is nothing okay that's a reason you
go to the linear the number of edges
remember everybody published limit
number of papers okay don't publish in
every conference every thing so probably
a maximum is 400 or 500 okay so this
this even you say on average the E
versus n is 500 you still have a
constant that's why it's constant number
of notes okay so this is a linear
algorithm is very fishy okay then if you
do case study this one we just run this
set K equals 15 okay and because we
don't have 15 columns it's too too
narrow so we only show 5 this is
database networking AI theory I are for
example you look at Siri remember this
this guy knows nothing about feared but
they put a soda starfox probably those
Siri people know these are the top three
things okay and a database actually you
may argue why we are DBA icd at least a
little higher than Sigma remember
nowadays we r DB and the ICD a cashier
many many co you know common authors
with Sigma V their ranking they do take
a lot of repeated authors on the other
hand they take more papers Sigma
lunatics 70 to 100 and VOD be take a war
honey more plots papers to get more
papers as you get more reputation if
they have the same authors okay so
that's a reason actually it's hard to
judge remember we don't have citation
count if you have citation count in DB
RP it would be a different game okay but
anyway then you say you can only do two
by type network then we got another
paper actually this way in the last year
kdd Tucson I we say we're not confined
to buy type because I by type is too
simple for example within database you
want to say who are the top researchers
are XML or on transaction
and on query processing okay so if you
want to know that they publish in the
same conference you just cannot
distinguish them so we need what we need
terms okay you said oh this is a
transaction management know this is a
query optimization okay you got
different terms only you introduce term
this value and an author will really
make sense right you can further
partition them okay so that's the reason
we say we need a more type the network
you have a research paper linking with
this this is from if you are familiar
with data warehouse this is more like a
star network okay that's why we call
this one is starnet schema you look at
we could start networks schema it's not
star schema because otherwise you you
you come here with the OLAP people okay
but we got this remember there are many
many operations actually follow this
star network okay then what we are going
to do clustering and a ranking is we
break these sing we think this thing is
a type to think this you get all these
small one week or this small type once
you break them apart you're not breaking
authors as author conference at
conference you actually even you break
them into tiny nose they still keeps
these stars structures okay the bigger
star getting too small stars you get
star from the hierarchies okay so and
every d star you may have ranking you
may have crossed for example you can get
a hardware cluster database clusters
theory cluster okay you can get this so
what we call the star network schema is
you get a center node which is more like
in data warehouse you have the star as a
center okay then you take all the
attributes or different other nodes you
put them aside you form a star network
okay and with the star network we can
study for example I can give you example
this is DVR p you have this this
different things okay this is delicious
delicious he also can get this for
example you can see in this is tacking
event the tagging event you may have
users
and you have websites you have tax ok so
you if you can get this network this is
IMDb it's about it you know the movie
database so you get a movie as a center
and here you have director here you have
an actor or actress and here you have
tighter and pot so you also came from
started full star network almost can be
anywhere okay then I just show you i
won't give you the detail because we
have lots of things to do so I just show
you this why essentially the general
principle is very similar to rank class
but you working a little more
complicated network okay but you
probably can't see the running we took
this country took this for Fears
database data mining machine learning
information in favor because this for
Fears nowadays is our intermingle
together we want to do clustering and do
we want to do ranking i will show you
one minor small cluster whatever get
okay here you can see suppose we look at
a cluster 1 parties kdd you see how
different intuition they go okay you
look at the kdd the zero iteration you
get database data mining machine
learning and some this bc is others you
look at this okay at the very beginning
is almost evenly distributed because it
randomly partitioned okay but after wire
after certain trajan okay like 10 CT
reaching and also the the stable
iteration you got once you get state
board you see this is 0.92 kdd belongs
to date money okay but of course you may
also TDD maybe run illiterate or the IR
there's worth machine learning little
forced a base okay but it obviously you
get the idea what about Max stonebraker
okay my stone care act is ninety percent
let me see 95% billions of David's he's
very dedicated David person you barely
go to like a data mining or machine
learning so that's why 000 person yes
there isn't there sweetie
okay but as a column that classifies the
paper has a data-mining you know the
date away is each paper remember in DB
RP record you have a conference you have
this paper ID this paper ID where one
way where you have the information about
authors another information of
information is about title okay that's
the only information you have you don't
have abstract don't have links okay but
then you have conference information
like a cig mod or vldb on the concert
data mining concertina basis is it one
of the clusters in your guitar ok yeah
actually this one that's a good question
actually this question is we first do
clustering once you do clustering you
actually get the database clustered a
man in cluster how do you get it later
your see we even you use robotic and get
it you don't need a human to intervene
okay of course we did intervene we put a
labor so this is david's the state money
okay but later you'll see how I claim
the robot can do it okay get the ladies
yeah you don't get Labor's but you use
just top two or three keywords you
market you get it okay do you your see
it's very interesting you you you will
see this state which we can information
retrieval you see the top information in
your cluster the top word wines
information when is retrieval okay then
of course you grab this top like XML you
get a wines xml wines ex Corey after
there are other quarries or something
optimizations other keywords but you
grab two is the XML ex Corey you
actually get a class or name ok so the
same thing you can see this ok yeah this
one I actually show you how things with
the machines running what you are see
okay when we do the all the for Fears
doing clustering what do you see finally
after a few rounds you get a stable you
can stay where these are numbers but you
can either see what the numbers for
example chip or a I cheaper re i belong
to the third column and cvpr beyond sir
column ECML third column I CMS or column
each Chrysler column what the column is
about yeah
you know this is a yeah at the first
column ed BTW i see de I the first
column let me see Potts Sigma V 0 DB
what's what's the first column tables so
that's very you just look at the top one
but there's one outlier you first see I
wouldn't mark anyone read cikm cikm
ERISA is a mingle with quite a few
things you look at this we don't know
this wife is ir ok this one's database
this is david's this is dave mining so
they have more IRS more somewhat data
mining then they have a little database
tiny little machine learning or AI or
something so you know this is a little
bit nervous or mixed conference we do
not know is even with fear it is but
anyway actually I RT reclaim this the
second I our conference or something
like that that's probably they had to
have some some arguments because the
highest wise I are let's just look at
davids cluster because we have many
database peeper here you can see what
you see while ice claim it you can get a
labor automatically the top keywords
database database is system data queries
system quarries management object
relational those are the races right as
all the game database is playing and
these are the conferences and these are
the rank I cannot see rank authors but
they are very dedicated database and
very productive okay so these are there
like a switch a duramax no break room I
carry you know a lot of names I think
almost every porous here David luma is
here so everybody is here right so
that's a Davis okay and we actually can
go deep her to do sub cluster you can
see this is a sub cluster of XML ex
Corey who are the constant ones search a
bit poor Victor vianney no Jairam Mike
Harry no you probably also know this
name they play a lot of games on x
correo x databases xml not only that you
actually hang can do the same game on
other database like flick
okay flickr you you type a raleigh what
you'll get okay we don't know but it
raleigh when the people got it actually
there are several clusters you can see
there are three clusters this cluster
likely will be raleigh north carolina is
character right and this rally or
raleigh bikes is famous back everybody
knows okay and this rally i really do
not know that i know this one is I
actress or some singer or somebody I'm
not a fan of the singers but at least
there's some thing related to other
rallies okay they automatically they can
do remember there is no human being no
pattern recognition involved okay we do
zero image processing but we actually
can get something pretty nice the bait
on tax of course so you probably can see
this is a pretty general framework we
actually did it on you know I am DB and
a delicious and Flickr and many things
using the same game okay so it's a very
interesting okay so we work out a system
actually the system car I next cube
while we call I next is information and
now so everything's I ok I next year now
I next act is the information next and
network enhance the text cube okay so we
have a cube we had tax we having with
net or get everything put together okay
so what do you see here like we did a
VOD be damned are you actually if you
have computer here you can just type in
on like it yesterday in being I just ask
them to type it being you know like I
next cube they actually can play with
this right right on spot and these are
different things actually I remember
last December hector garcia-molina
actually came to UIC he asked me what's
new I said oh we got a system pretty
interesting I told him he said all you
cannot for me I was a department head of
Stanford I do all the evaluation all the
fears he'd have graphics he look at the
names and he times his theory he looked
names he said oh this system is pretty
trust or as to why he said oh the
Stanford professor are on the top hahaha
so that then we probably say this one
has no training okay now we look at what
about I add training inside I a lot of
people wander training it won't say I
want twist it I don't like your you're
at once so that means you what you say i
do have prior knowledge i want to put in
okay i want to do training so the input
is not only this network but i give you
a bunch of class labors it can you do
better can't do worse or can you really
do it okay of course it would be
different game the previous game was was
a clustering game now it's a
classification game okay so what we can
see is this okay now the game becomes a
little interesting for example if you
want to say what emails likely could be
more terrorists ok suppose you want to
get this so you may put some suspicious
users or words the emails as a training
set you put it down there then with this
wine you do the network analysis you may
be able to analyze which email likely
worry more some terrorist activities the
same thing like we actually work with
the US Army Research Lab they give us
like a 16 million dollars of course it's
big Center you more quite a few
universities and we do information
network analysis you will be able to to
classify which things these are related
military camps ok now the general
philosophy is this kind of picture ok
you got you you mark some class say this
one state money suppose this one is your
knowledge then you can propagate from
the conference down to papers and you
can prove that down to authors and these
propagation may help you actually to
classify databases okay so the
interesting thing is the class labor you
got sometimes you think is funny you
give a labor to the conference at it get
very high performance on the authors and
on the keywords because they are linked
okay links things can propagate ok let's
week or knowledge propagation so we work
a new paper or news new software called
ginette mine ok G is a graph a crease is
a graph regulations under nice so we use
thus the network mining ok you can sync
it this way and the general philosophy
is you use a graph-based regularization
network the regularization base is some
kind of smooth you can think do some
kind of boosting or something you do
something smoothing you get a better
classification accuracy ok so the
general idea is you use consistence see
some assumption you do this this
maximization some kind of propagation
based on the class labour you can you
can propagate down to the other parts ok
i probably will not give you this mass
formula to the explanation you just know
this is some kind of mass formula you
actually can get the normalization terms
then you get this like a some kind of
estimation on the maximum likelihood
then you find her you can do you know
this game ok the students who work on
that Hector she got very good training
on that originally when she did an
undergrad study so what we still do is
we take these four areas ok database
data mining AI information retrieval so
we gotta you know these tents islands or
papers and authors and we actually get
these three things we do different kind
of training ok now we actually compared
with a few quite right or algorithm need
to classification they do graph
classification network classification
and these are pretty influential papers
published like in nips in in ICM error
in all these conferences we do the
comparison ok i will now give you the
very detail but you see this result we
the major difference is we use
heterogeneous multi type the network
they just trade everything just like a
normal i equal play they just are doing
this now you can see the difference
these are three other algorithms this
arch in admin
a cpt is Arthur conference paper and
tighter okay these four things for my
network but they don't do that we put
the same network as input but they don't
do the classification or type these four
types and we do it okay now you see the
the accuracy this is how many percentage
of author and hummin percentage of paper
you mark them you see these are some
paper in David's this is the paper in
machinery okay then what you can see is
you get 0.1% training data and you want
to do all the others as testing okay
then you can see we can get eighty-two
percent okay they got it is only you
look at others they won't get it that
much inspector you think about this is
twenty-six percent total for Fears this
is almost random random guess right you
get twenty-five percent is the real
random gasps okay so you get 0.5 percent
you can get get pretty hot ok this is
accuracy young authors remember even
author themselves it's ambiguous a very
much fear like for me some people call
me a database person some people call me
at a mining first it so it's a little
ambiguous okay so and for papers you get
this for conferences you get a very high
accuracy you can see this because a
conference usually the fear is decided
ok we'll paper sometimes is all time
biggest these are the ranking reader
that one is a clustering this ranking
results you can see database top-ranked
keywords are these yeah this is data
money this is a I this is the
information Airy table so you can see
you don't need to get a labor you
actually we're know them okay and these
are top ranked the database researchers
the remaining researchers AI researchers
information okay this ranking to some
extent is pretty a lot of people pretty
recognize this okay and these are the
other conferences okay so it's very good
result remember there's no real human
being but we did to have a little
training we took some 0
one percent you know paper or are or you
know like authors okay so but you can
see with training Acura dart get even
better than without training you can see
that you just look at the names and the
conference is super C is better okay so
with training is good then with this
classification clustering what I want to
say is also you can dig out a pretty
hidden knowledge in the network we call
road discovery okay what are the road
discovery okay suppose you give a
network like this okay then if you
really can do suppose this is the army
communication network okay so of course
the army will give us the state all
right so but on your hand after you to
this row discovery you may form a little
clean and neat network hierarchy call a
different levels okay so then you may be
even suppose you can even recognize who
are the commander's like the center one
these are captains these are the really
foot soldiers right so at the end so
whether you can see the network so
probably is more useful than this one
right okay so can we really do this of
course you say if we can do this
automatically just give me a networking
and do that you will be great right if
you have intelligence you can see how
they are the enemy army instructor okay
but with we do we cannot do army we
don't even have data but we do have DVR
p what we do is we say we extract
semantic information from the links we
can of course there are lots of tricky
things you can see but there are lots of
attractive things you find I can get
then I'll show you we got a paper in
this year cked conference the tree while
he was my actually is my first year
student but he's very very capable ask
him to do this and he did a marvelous
work he just say we with TB RP network
you know nothing about it which
university this guy from you may be able
to identify who are whose adviser and my
advisee ok that's pretty tricky you
think about this but there are something
you
no is adviser advisee if adviser advisee
never published paper together there's
no information we can I get it okay you
have the public paper together somehow
okay so but how can we get this okay
we're actually doing the major major
chick is you don't give too much
knowledge it will give some common sense
knowledge as constraints you can get it
why do not give too much knowledge
because the process for exemplary in
Stanford it's very different from like a
University of Munich or some University
in England or in another know singapore
someplace so you give it a rule it may
work in stanford university or in the US
it doesn't work in singapore okay so
then you get lots of errors so the rule
we finally put it this into network is
very common sense rules one rule says
the advisor actually it has a longer
publication history okay then the advice
see at the time of supervision that
probably is true another thing we give
is the advice see becomes adviser will
not become advisee again okay so that
means once you become professor will not
become student again okay somebody's is
to okay maybe seven seven dollars but
anyway we we use this common-sense rule
ike this you're very common every
country will take it then we just do
this basic is constraint propagation you
just come find this confine that you
find I can get it okay so you can see
we've construct a network of the authors
and papers and year you do
simplification fabricated things like
this okay the part we have is author
paper paper year starting time ending
time ranking score using this of course
the highly ranked alliances this number
one professor could be candidate for the
or likely will be the advisor then their
number two advisor actually we do
sometimes we cannot make a decision will
give you two or three based on the
ranking school so with this ranking
score we do this we call a time
constraint probability factor graph
remember the time is critical
if you don't have a year we cannot do it
you do have a year okay in DB RP so we
take the starting ending time doing this
this propagation so you probably see the
result actually is pretty respective
because we checked there's a message
geology project and aig rh project they
do have adviser advisee relationship we
do not use that for training but we use
this as a checking okay then what you
can see I give you a few examples
probably is no one guide and I put in
actually the Joseph Heller Stan who had
juice even Harrison's advisor actually
we got to we originally started what's
wrong because Joseph Harrison got peach
in Wisconsin the shoe to advisor is Mike
Stonebreaker and Jeff Norton we said max
number cannot be but actually we checked
in detail max number was his master
advisor another interesting thing is
even in their PhD committee finally
found max Stonebreaker steer serve as a
coat advisor on the committee so that's
the reason we actually right right so
even he got fishy in Wisconsin and this
was my own student he got to advisor
China and Jerry hon okay i know because
Chang was her master sees his visor so
to the accent is true we took a search
brand he did not even got PhD but his
advice or that time at least we do not
know whether he finally Craig he's not
we were not certain the visor is Rajiv
Gidwani actually is true okay so that
you've got something pretty interesting
the accuracy is pretty good and running
time is reasonable okay so that's about
a row discovery another interesting
thing is with information network
analysis you can do data cleaning and
data validation okay i will show you
that this actually was done by Xiao Qing
is here okay why interesting data
cleaning work is object distinction you
know there's an object con solid
conciliation is centuries you get
different names like you know like a
bill clinton William Clinton fancy oh
that's the same person but object
distinction is
you got away one okay there are 14 way
once actually there's Carrie same last
name same first name in DB RP and the
object distinction is partying them into
14 slots automatically say which paper
belongs to who ok so that's a really
hard task actually when charging first
posed to me actually said I said it's
almost impossible because I'm not sure
because three-way walls you know
co-author a different time I they are
probably the same conference okay so
actually there's another one shouting
fun is seventy two sons and three albums
carries same name as forgotten ok so
those are the very hard things to
distinguish but he finally did it ok if
you look at those things interesting
thing is he came back to me a few days
later I should mark this one is a little
darker but he told me you know it's not
just the collaborations with the same
author occasionally but they are degrees
of high collaborations you for example
just a way while this UNC we wanna she
actually collaborated with Joanie on
digg months because she got PG UCLA okay
but the other way one like a he got PhD
under Hong Jin Lou collaborating with
Sanjay newest shaming because later he
joined shavings group and there's a
another way one if you see you at the at
SUNY Buffalo because my student GMP
actually published papers that's his
student but the problem is this GMP
actually working with this way while
also or humans this way while it was
going straight up for a different way it
was and you know at the same time that's
a reason you know you know make sense is
much much mario but the problem the
interesting thing is what we heart the
first thing is we use a link paste
similarity use a random walk the random
walk has a good thing is this okay you
were automatically judge which link is
more important you think about this okay
it's a conference link is more important
or co-author link is more important okay
if you use a random walk you're
automatically co-author probably carry
more weight than co-conference because
you'll publish it one conference
Sigma may take you know 100 papers okay
you're cold conference same conference
doesn't mean that much but you got only
three or four author one paper so they
have tiger dick but another thing is who
is going to train it you got like we got
a half a meaning authors you your
they're not even to find a good training
set in a way one who is going to train
where you are okay but the interesting
thing is we said there are clean data in
DB RP we use self training what is self
training then we seem DVR p okay you
will be able to find some kind of clean
day just show you for example Johannes
Kirk okay you're not 14 your highness
Kirk's in DB Ravi actually is only one
okay so why because a girl is not a very
potter some people are even have a hard
time even pronounce it right okay and
your highness of course in germany maybe
it's okay but maybe here overall in DB
RP is not that popular not like John but
anyway we took this as Halle gathers you
it do a little you know statistical
thing you'll get those are the clean
data you take those clean data runs
through this you actually will get a
parameters you get a training see how
sharp the knife should be to cut it okay
and with this you you know the parameter
you actually can training using svm or
something you can get something pretty
good i'm going to another interesting
thing is about a clustering remember to
get a cluster you can use single link
complete link original and all these and
finery searching found it using average
link and a refine it okay then you get a
really good knife you can cut it okay i
will show you just a few example super
can see this example there's a jew
Heller Stan you probably know him but
they are quite a few to Harrisons agree
on there but they actually not a
confusing each other because you have
different min or initial ok so we play
the trick we put a Joe Harris to Jill
Heller stands actually there's three we
all took their mirroring this you're out
we merge them together see whether our
system can do it okay
then to our surprise actually the system
any two headers and they say I'm whining
% sure the precision active twenty
percent is right but we do have some
record not everybody we can do the we
dare to say it right ok so the relay car
is not new percent but it's still decent
job if you look away while I perceive us
you're not so good ok which is true
because they are 40 of them but we check
we want it one by one we found actually
it's not that bad you think about this
14 we once we got the 13 right only this
one was merged with eating up by this
way one okay but this way while to
suffer five papers to the UNC Chapel
Hill a while but this Ungh everyone she
only suffered ish even sever six to the
Buffalo a while okay actually these 11
papers was all muddied it with champagne
my previous student because he
collaborated with all the three at the
same time same conference right so
that's a that's otherwise the accuracy
should be higher okay yeah you just get
out to that he said some people are
asking what about to we want so authors
said papery though I cannot do that sure
then we look at another one is data
validation okay data validation actually
was also done by Shawsheen that's why
she actually got cked 2008 dissertation
war he got several great piece of BC's
work that data mining people really love
it okay so this was about a truce
validation is you get a network you
actually can consolidation came back
from a one summer intern is not in
microsoft research but he came back to
me he said some company people asked him
to say on the web somebody is telling
truth some webpages is sly okay you get
a conflict information can you write a
program say which was right hey that's
almost seems impossible to do it right
who but he came back he said he wanted
to think about this to the research
original so sorry this is very hard you
know how could you get it but then he
work out a very interesting Messer I
better show you the master instead of
saying this he actually really got a
real data set containing such thing
which actually is a non icing is
structured ok this structure is much
better than the natural language things
is very very you know funny here you
look at this this is a book called rapid
contextual design ok you perv do now
know the book I didn't never read a book
okay well when shocking bring this book
a look check all these popular websites
ok to probably everybody's surprise they
all give different answers ok of course
a book only can have one right set of
ulcers of course you may say Barnes
number is not doing too bad because the
a1 book is the right answer barnes noble
only missed this middle name for the
middle of the second author ok it's not
too bad but there some did a really
Bismil ok it's really bad but but the
problem is if you cannot trust the barn
over even who you trust how could you
get right answer ok so shocking work out
a very narrow Messer information network
analysis ok take this while it's a game
ok you can think these are the real book
these are the websites who setting books
like a you know barnes noble you know
powers book these are where they stated
the authors ok so you can see some
actually have more tense connection some
have more sparse connection then you
previous eight with us just watch this
network can i judge which one is more
trustable looks almost impossible to
think about it actually if you really
think about it there are some rules you
can get ok of course one rule is the
assumption this something can be
extended this one said there's only one
shoe facts for property for the book is
true you know it's only one true set of
authors ok but for some events like a
political events you know Democrats and
the Republicans a debate you even do not
know which ones do ok
but something actually like Obama you
know you say Obama is a present with
shoe but if you look at a time you know
time axis you check the older web the
Obama is a senator of e9 okay there was
a you know Democrats candidate or
president-elect or something you get
quite a few different titles which was
true they are truly to a different time
slots okay so we just assume there's one
we do not say there's older where but
there's a newer web okay we don't deal
with this now even something is a little
much surer than the others you look at
Jennifer Widom and Jada with them you
know the sort of have degree of to
choose but probably generally there may
be even more accurate but these two
actually becomes a critical one okay
this one says the force statement user
is more diverse okay it's a little hard
to converge which is true when you
heading mistakes you make different
mistakes okay for example you just
assume that the police you know catch
three robbers robber bank ok the police
Stefan not say we have a panel
discussion okay what they do is they
isolate those thieves ok the question
one by one why they isolate them just
because they know when they want to
Terrell I likely they tear some
different versions they wouldn't
coverage okay when is having shoes
likely there could be converge okay
that's a golden rule for us another one
of course is the trust ability if the
website keep telling you the truth you
say all this website hyper trust more
otherwise if we keep telling lies I
probably ignore you okay so with this
you can build a choose or confidence
propagation game this game is somewhat
like hits algorithm or you think history
habit you know haves and our 30 pages
you can turn around propagate this one
we can do it okay for example you can
think they're hops their authority okay
at the very beginning you may say the
websites and facts I don't know which
one is more trustful they are equal okay
then even they are equal okay once you
build this network they become unequal
again why you look at this this is owed
to is a book there are three guys said
this should be this author there's one
guy said you should be author f4 okay
based on the Rue if you do not know
anything you press a this one likely
will be true this one likely will be the
force okay and if this was true maybe
this guide heading this FY maybe a
little chore then you know w2 because W
already made mistakes so you do this you
start propagating okay of course you
with the massive you get tiny network in
our work with massive network you like
the Google can play the game because its
massive okay so that's all finally you
can make it work okay of course this
game the difference is they are you know
the computation is not additive its
propagation probability you know those
kind of computation on confidence comes
in you use different formulas accretion
really did this one you see this is the
truth finder competing with barnes noble
why pick up bars number bunch number
google rank number while hey you if you
can be number one you can beat many
people okay so and if you look at the
shower chinga this these many books from
8.com he randomly pick one hundred books
and judge whether it's good or not in
order to see almost every inch okay the
choose finder coded by xiao xin if he
can do better no worse comparing to
barnes noble okay so but actually it's
not not because you're Shane is Magic
charging takes many websites away
including Barnes number itself refinery
can beat bars number okay so actually he
even did this is try to see which
bookstore is much festival and the
google rank Barnes number number one and
the powerbook number three but actually
there choose trustworthiness wise these
free three no-name bookstores actually
ranks pretty high
hahahaha but anyway they probably only
publish option i really do not know but
they published last but they do a better
job right but a power spoke icicle issue
to blame their data input ER they really
go to pretty abysmal you know ranking
this one is about data validation using
network and another thing is using
network you can do search you can't do
similarity search okay i'll just show
you the very last one remember people
doing similarity search you say how
similar we r DV vs sigmod if you just
ask me profit or they know it but you
ask d BRP it's hard to say because they
are added distance it's very long okay
very big for example if i ask you you
know who is most similar to Crystal
Palace's that's also a tough tough
question and we did it in two very high
quality there chase the trick is we use
information network but the question is
much harder to answer in the sense even
for human being you ask who is most
similar to crystal follows us you press
I don't know it depends on which
standard a similar is just because they
have tight connection by co-authoring
are they attend same conference or
publishing same conferences are they
exactly what kind of same topics okay so
actually these different thing by
network you can use Pass Ski schema okay
what is past schema look at this this is
paper this is the author this term this
conference if you want to say who is
most similar to Christmas villosus you
can go to paper back to the author what
do you got most similar one aries
co-authors but if you go from author
paper to conference the most similar
ones is they published in a similar set
of conferences but if you go through
author paper to turn what you got is
they work on exact same topic even they
may not even publish in the same
conference okay using same terms so
you will proceed we took Christmas
fellows as a quarry okay this APA means
author paper author who you got it you
see spirits Parvati me to Jamieson you
know pan you know most of these are his
students including yuri less Kovac
actually I think flick corn is also his
student what's its gilded you can check
back i am not want any % sure but anyway
you this similarity it could be
co-authors because molarity is lower but
anyway these are author paper author but
if you go to author paper conference
paper author you go through a conference
you can see the most similar wines me
the reason is i publish both in davis
and dave mining colony it is the same
way right so Andrea kashi agora also
right but if you look at exactly terms
actually GM pay or srini jeffrey
actually ming ming and qing actually
higher than me because I even probably
the same conference at work on different
things I published like association
rules you say another I will forget that
he will do different things that's a
reason okay you get different things so
that's very telling if you single it
based on many many papers many many
titles this network big network in
terror something very smart we even
tried on flickr okay you can see we take
this flower this lotus flower is the
quarry number one the most similar is to
accept of course then we want to find in
most similar pictures using tags okay
but if you use tag image user use tag
imageshack using this way you that's why
we say ITI image tag image you just look
at this you say this is ok but not that
good because this bird is not lotus
flower okay but if you use image image
tag image group going back this group
tag actually is quite telling now go
through group tag you see those are our
lotus flower even this flower is not
blossom yet these are steer loaders
okay so you actually can see it's very
telling so that's the nice thing you you
see this similarity search using network
actually can't get Sigma V DV is much
similar than say Sigma Lewis kdd
sigmod with stripper act okay that even
Sigma was sick graph they all carry sick
but it's still pretty far apart okay so
we actually can give you a conference e
which conference most similar okay i'll
give you add a spa we don't give you a
sigma because Sigma would automatically
you cannot hair we give you that so I
say who is more Sigma is similar to that
spa you use the PageRank personalized
pagerank you got a device i see de Vere
DB Sigma Texas reason is that's why it's
working database they put at a higher
wise highly ranked line will put it high
actually that's why is not that highly
wrecked so they are not similar to Sigma
you would not agree small similar to
Sigma so but if you use our cpa pc based
on our authors remember sigma house or
may not always want to send paper so
that's why so what do you got is that
that's why is most similar to dexa why
ap web cikm you know that's definite
alley right you think about this you get
levels of conference clearly rather you
just take highly ranked line give it to
him ok so this similarity at you're
using massive network is very very
telling so the similar thing we use we
competing with sim rank the interesting
thing is sim rank going way way way far
ahead to fetch neighbors what do you
fetch after many iterations we'd run
many iterations you got Sigma ball
singer is foundation chains they have
HPT see of course they have cidr but
they have something actually pretty
strange but here we got you can see
Sigma almost similar to this conferences
or joiners so this one sim rank even
they are expensive they tend to grab a
little remote neighbors and he
there we follow this path you can
actually tear quite choose okay so
that's why this similarity function foot
foot for our new measure at least very
good okay now I finally finish the whole
thing of course we got lots of students
did a lot of things there others inside
and out there but D Singh all related to
information networks but I think it's
very exciting in a sense the information
network is specially hook with state
ways we call DB internet actually can
give the database a new life because
remember we'll just take DVR p or a
flicker or something as an example TVR
he is structured okay with this
structure network you do far better than
the web okay remember people or Davis
people were bullied by the web people
say oh we can do more things actually
database people can do many many more
things because database hold the rear
assets of data and it is structured okay
with the structure the database you will
do far better than many many people
working in a ir ir okay that's why i say
the database linking team up with
information network you'll get a new
knowledge base and it's very powerful
knowledge base ok so that's i finish my
talk these are the recent papers
including xiaochun's several papers
these are all this year's paper and of
course with now we publish mostly in KD
d sigma we are give a tutorial and we
also publish in ww conference but
there's a 10 pasta okay okay so thank
you very much
the reason we got the spies that's why
this year's in Japan really want to go
there haha
yes in there the truth discovery work
that we describe do you consider the
fact that some websites are poking
information from each other yeah very
very good point charges original one
consider a little but the copycat
effects is is very tricky thing I do
have a student working on this copycat
problem okey last year lunatone he is in
AT&T research now she she published two
papers in vldb actually two paper both
side shot scenes paper actually did a
follow-up work it did a really good I
enjoy reading that two papers we still
work on it I think it's a very good
problem on this choose one the copycat
effect definitely it's very interesting
one and it's also very tricky one yeah
it's very good point
okay yeah thank you much okay thank you